>> Laura: I AM LAURA INGRAHAM,
AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT HANG
IN THE BALANCE.
AN ECONOMY AS EVIDENCED BY
TODAY'S JOB REPORT.
IT'S ROARING, MY FRIENDS.
AND IN IMMIGRATION POLICY THAT
MAKES SENSE.
MY SIMPLE MESSAGE IS THIS.
LET'S NOT STOP SUCCESS, AMERICA
AND, I'M TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WITH DIFFERENT RACES, AND THEY
ARE DECIDING THE NECK AND NECK
RACE HERE BETWEEN MARTHA
McSALLY REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT KYRSTEN SINEMA.
WE WILL TALK TO MAKE SALLY JUST
AHEAD BUT FIRST WE WANTED TO
HEAR FROM THE VOTERS THEMSELVES.
WE START WITH THE PRESSING ISSUE
OF IMMIGRATION AND HOW ILLEGALS
HAVE AFFECTED THIS BORDER STATE.
RAYMOND ARROYO JOINS ME FOR THE
QUESTIONING OF THIS GROUP.
HERE'S PART ONE.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH AN ISSUE
THAT'S FRONT AND CENTER RIGHT
NOW, AND THUS THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE CARAVANS
BARRELING TOWARD OUR BORDER, AND
A LOT OF THE MIGRANTS COULD END
UP IN YOUR BACKYARD.
HOW MANY OF YOU THINK YOU SHOULD
WELCOME ALL MEMBER OF THE
CARAVAN DESPITE EVIDENCE THAT
THERE ARE CRIMINALS WITHIN THE
GROUP.
RAISE YOUR HAND.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE CARAVAN.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S
CRIMINALS IN THE GROUP.
>> YOU DON'T THINK THERE ARE ANY
CRIMINALS?
>> I THINK THERE ARE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WHO ARE TRYING TO GET
AWAY FROM FEAR AND MILITARY
DICTATORS AND ALL KINDS OF OTHER
PROBLEMS IN THEIR COUNTRIES.
>> ACTUALLY, GRIFF JENKINS WITH
OUR CORRESPONDENT DOWN, AND HE'S
BEEN WITH THE CARAVAN FOR A
NUMBER OF DAYS.
HE INTERVIEWED VARIOUS MEMBERS
OF THE CARAVAN AND THIS IS WHAT
HE FOUND OUT LAST SUNDAY.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO BREAK THE
LAW TO GET BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES?
>> HE SAID HE WANTS TO APPLY FOR
A PARDON FOR THE FELONY HE
COMMITTED.
>> CAN YOU ASK HIM HAPPENED?
>> A THIRD-DEGREE FELONY.
ATTEMPT OF MURDER.
>> DAN, YOUR REACTION?
>> MY REACTION IS THAT MOST OF
THESE WOMEN, CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ARE COMING HERE FOR
ASYLUM AND DOING AT THE RIGHT
WAY.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO A PORT OF
ENTRY, YOU HAVE TO TURN YOURSELF
IN AT A PORT OF ENTRY AND YOU
HAVE TO APPLY FOR ASYLUM.
IF THEY DON'T FIT ASYLUM, THEN
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK.
IF THEY MEET THE CRITERIA FOR
ASYLUM, THEY ARE NOT BREAKING
THE LAW.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK WOMEN FEEL
ABOUT THE CARAVAN?
>> I DON'T WANT THEM IN OUR
COUNTRY AND WOMEN DON'T WANT
THEM IN OUR COUNTRY.
WOMEN WANT SECURITY.
>> I SAW YOU NODDING YOUR HEAD
OR SHAKING HER HEAD A MINUTE
AGO.
>> I DON'T CARE IF NOBODY IS A
CRIMINAL.
HAVE SOME RESPECT FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND DO WITH THE LEGAL
WAY.
I'M A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT, I
SWITCHED OVER FOR TRUMP JUST TO
VOTE FOR HIM.
I'VE ALWAYS VOTE FOR HIM.
THEY ARE SUFFERING EVERYWHERE IN
THE WORLD.
CHARITY STARTS AT HOME, LET'S
TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
THEN WE DO WITH THE LEGAL WAY,
NOT ILLEGALLY.
>> I SEE ROY SITTING NEXT TO
TERRY, CHOMPING AT THE BIT.
>> TRUMP SAYS IT WHEN THEY DON'T
WANT THE CARAVAN TO COME IN, I'M
SURE A NUMBER OF WOMEN WOULDN'T
WANT TO BE AROUND DONALD TRUMP.
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST, I WOULD
SAY, LET'S GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
LET'S PROCESS EACH CASE, CASE BY
CASE.
IF THERE WAS A PROPER SYSTEM OF
IMMIGRATION IN PLACE THEN WE
COULD PROPERLY VET THOSE THAT
WERE TRYING TO ENTER INTO THE
COUNTRY AND DECIPHER WHO WAS A
CRIMINAL AND WHO WAS SEEKING
ASYLUM.
>> JULIE, HE WANTED TO SAY WHAT?
>> THERE IS A SYSTEM AND HOW TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY.
I'M AN IMMIGRANT AND I DID AT
THE RIGHT WAY.
YOU FILE YOUR PAPERWORK, GET
APPROVED AND COME HERE.
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT NOW OUR SYSTEM IS BEING
GAMED.
THE ASYLUM SYSTEM, IT'S A GOOD
THING TO ALLOW PEOPLE IN FOR
ASYLUM FOR CERTAIN CREDIBLE
FEARS.
FEAR OF RELIGIOUS PERSECUTION,
ETHNIC CLEANSING, TRUE FEAR OF
PERSECUTION FOR POLITICAL
OUTLOOK.
BUT -- AND WE HAVE THE MEXICAN
AMBASSADOR AND GUATEMALAN
INTERIOR ON LAST NIGHT ON THE
ANGLE AND THEY BOTH SAID THAT
MOST OF THESE MIGRANTS
OVERWHELMINGLY ARE ECONOMIC.
THEY ARE COMING BECAUSE LIKE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD, IT'S A GREAT
PLACE TO LIVE.
AND THEY WANT TO COME HERE.
>> WHAT THE MEDIA ISN'T SHOWING
IS THEY ARE PASSING LIVE FEEDS
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MEXICO
WITH THIS CARAVAN.
THE CARAVAN IS ASSAULTING POLICE
OFFICERS, AND THEY ARE TEARING
APART THE COUNTRY OF MEXICO.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THEY ARE, THE
OWN MEXICAN RESIDENTS THAT ARE
LIVING THERE.
THEY ARE SAYING GO BACK TO YOUR
COUNTRY AND STOP TEARING APART
HOURS.
>> BUT THEY WERE ALSO HAVING A
GOOD TIME AND BE WELCOME IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
>> BUT THEY ARE TAKING THIS
MIND-SET AND BRINGING IT DOWN TO
THIS BORDER.
>> I'M AN IMMIGRANT TO THIS
COUNTRY AND I CAME HERE LEGALLY.
IT TOOK ME TEN YEARS TO GET MY
CITIZENSHIP AND I ALSO WORKED IN
THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY.
THEY LOOK AT THIS CARAVAN AND
THIS IS AN ORGANIZED GROUP.
I REALLY FEEL IT'S AN INVASION
OF OUR COUNTRY.
THIS IS AN ORGANIZED CARAVAN AND
PEOPLE HAVE TRUCKS AND ARE
HAULING PEOPLE ON THE FREEWAY
AND THEN THEY LOOK AT THE
CARAVAN AND THEY ARE FINDING
THAT 80% OF IT ARE MEN.
AND LESS THAN 20% ARE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
>> THE OFFICIALS THAT ARE
MONITORING THIS, THE MEXICAN
OFFICIALS AND THE GUATEMALAN
OFFICIALS THAT WE TALK TO AND
INTERVIEWED HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
THEY ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
ABLE-BODIED WORKING AGE MEN.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN BEING PUT IN
THE FRONT AND ALMOST LIKE A
HUMAN SHIELD.
NO MATTER WHAT PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT IMMIGRATION, THAT'S FINE.
BUT IT'S NOT IMMIGRATION AND
THAT'S A FACT.
YOU ARE ALL FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND POLITICAL
PERSUASIONS, HOW MANY OF YOU
OBJECT TO THE WORD INVASION?
SO THAT'S ABOUT HALF.
HOW MANY OBJECT TO THE USE OF
THE WORD INVASION ARE DEMOCRATS.
RAISE YOUR HAND.
>> THEY ARE COMING HERE WITH
THEIR OWN FLAG, WAVING THEIR OWN
FLAG, IT'S AN INVASION.
>> I'M SORRY, IT'S AN INVASION.
YOU WANT TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY?
DON'T BURN OUR FLAG.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> DO I NEED TO SEPARATE YOU
TWO?
>> WE HAVE TO GIVE EVERYBODY A
POINT HERE.
>> IN TERMS OF BEING ORGANIZED,
HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM
CARAVANS OF BOATS THAT CAME OVER
WITH WHAT WE CALL PILGRIMS WHICH
WERE SIMPLY EUROPEAN REFUGEES?
HOW IS THAT ANY DIFFERENT?
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT CARAVANS
AND INVASIONS, BUT WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS THE
ORIGINAL INVASION OF WHERE WE
SIT?
WE ARE ON INVADED LAND, THAT WE
INVADED.
WELL, NOT I.
NOT ALIVE.
BUT PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE ME
INVADED THIS LAND.
>> Laura: HOW MANY HERE
BELIEVE THAT IN PART, THESE
CARAVANS HAVE A POLITICAL
MOTIVATION IN THE ORGANIZATION?
RAISE YOUR HAND.
>> >> I JUST WANT TO HEARKEN
BACK TO WHAT YOU SAID, AND WHAT
THAT GENTLEMAN SAID IS PROBABLY
TRUE.
BEEN GAMING THE SYSTEM EVER
SINCE WE ARRIVED BY THE
MAYFLOWER, AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK WE HAVE THE SYSTEM.
I GOT HERE IN 1969 AND I'VE BEEN
HEARING THE SAME STORY OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE THE RULE
OF LAW AND NEED TO ENFORCE IT.
WHEN YOU SAID WELCOME, I SAID
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT MEANS.
WE ARE A WELCOMING COUNTRY AND
WE CAN VET EACH AND EVERY
INDIVIDUAL TO GIVE US IN    IN T
INDIVIDUAL TO GIVE US IN    IN E
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE LEARNED IN THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THIS WAS A HALF REPUBLICAN AND
HALF DEMOCRAT GROUP.
ONLY ONE PERSON SAID THEY WANTED
TO WELCOME THE CARAVAN.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING, IT'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT I FOUND ONE WE
WERE IN TEXAS LAST WEEK.
NOW AS YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS MOVED OR VOWED TO MOVE
15,000 TROOPS TO THE BORDER.
>> ALREADY MOVED THE INITIAL TO
THE TEXAS BORDER WHICH IS WHERE
MOST OF THESE MIGRANTS WILL
ARRIVE WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA IS NOT
RESPONDING.
WE WANT TO PLAY THIS FOR YOU AND
GET YOUR REACTION.
>> THEY ARE EVEN TAKING OUR
BRAVE TROOPS AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES, AND THE MEN AND
WILLING TO MAKE WOMEN OF OF THE
FAMILIES ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
>> Laura: RAISE YOUR HAND IF
YOU THINK THERE IS NO REASON TO
HAVE THE U.S. MILITARY AT OUR
BORDER, IT'S PURELY POLITICS.
WE HAVE TO GIVE EVERYBODY HERE A
VOICE.
>> IT IS PURELY POLITICS AND I
BELIEVE THIS RHETORIC IS
DANGEROUS.
WE ARE THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD AND WE ARE
SCARED OF A CARAVAN FULL OF
FOLKS WHO ARE COMING TO SEEK
ASYLUM.
I FEEL LIKE WE COULD HAVE BETTER
USE OF OUR TROOPS TIME AND
RESOURCES, HERE IN ARIZONA, WE
HAVE OVER 500 HOMELESS YOUTH.
ONE IN FIVE CHILDREN GO HUNGRY.
I DON'T FEEL THIS IS A GREAT WAY
TO UTILIZE OUR NATION'S
RESOURCES.
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL WHEN
WE USE THE WORD INVASION.
>> Laura: HOW MANY PEOPLE HERE
ARE AWARE OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
DRUGS COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
THAT COME THROUGH ARIZONA?
LET'S HAVE SOME GUESSES.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF DRUGS COME
THROUGH ARIZONA?
BINGO.
40% OF THE DRUGS COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY COME THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE POOREST BORDER.
>> I DON'T FEEL THEY NEED A
BABYSITTER.
>> AND IT IS A QUESTION FOR THE
CROWD.
HERE'S ANOTHER QUESTION.
DO YOU PREFER OUR MILITARY TO
ENFORCE THE BORDERS OF OTHER
COUNTRIES, WHICH THEY ARE DOING
IN SYRIA AND IRAQ, ON
AFGHANISTAN, MOSTLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, OR, ENFORCING IF
NECESSARY THE BORDERS OF THE
UNITED STATES?
FIRST QUESTION.
DO YOU WANT THE MILITARY AND
FORCING THE BORDERS OF OTHER
COUNTRIES OR THE BORDER OF THE
UNITED STATES?
LET'S GO TO -- >> I WOULD BE
TOTALLY OKAY WITH THE MILITARY
PROTECTING OUR BORDERS PROVIDED
THAT WE WERE NOT BEING ATTACKED.
I FEEL LIKE THE NATION IS
CRIPPLED IN FEAR RIGHT NOW AND
EACH PARTY, AND EVERYBODY IS
POLARIZED BECAUSE EVERYBODY IS
EITHER BAD OR EVERYBODY IS GOOD.
AND THERE IS NO IN THE MIDDLE.
REGARDLESS OF THE CARAVAN, THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER ALREADY WHO BLOCKED THAT
ARE REALLY SEEKING ASYLUM.
WE CAN'T LUMP EVERYBODY
TOGETHER.
IT'S ONE OR THE OTHER.
>> Laura: DOES ASYLUM MEAN --
>> I BELIEVE THE CARAVAN IS
PROBABLY A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
>> Laura: THE CARAVAN IS
OVERWHELMINGLY -- ACCORDING TO
DHS AND THE MEXICAN AND
GUATEMALAN OFFICIALS, THERE IS A
LOT OF GREAT PEOPLE.
BUT OVERWHELMINGLY WHEN THEY ARE
INTERVIEWED, OVERWHELMINGLY
BEFORE THEY ARE COACHED OR
INTERVIEWED, THEY WANT TO WORK
OR THEY WANT -- WITH THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE HERE AND I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
VERY DIFFERENT FROM A SYSTEMATIC
ETHNIC CLEANSING OR A SYSTEMATIC
PERSECUTION.
THE CHRISTIANS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST ARE BEING BURIED
ALIVE.
SO WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WITH
OUR TERMINOLOGY.
ANOTHER ISSUE IS THE ISSUE OF
RACE.
I WANT TO PLAY IT FOR THIS
GROUP.
ALL OF YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS, WHAT'S BEING SAID
LATELY ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THE RHETORIC OF THIS RACIST,
HEARTLESS, SOULLESS MAN WILL
LEAD TO MORE VIOLENCE.
YES, I SAID THAT.
AND A LOT OF AMERICANS BELIEVE
IT, TOO.
>> IT IS FEAR AND HATE, AND IT
IS RACIST.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALWAYS USED
FEAR TO HIS ADVANTAGE.
>> SHOW OF HANDS, HOW MANY THINK
THOSE MEDIA APPRAISALS ARE
ACCURATE?
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR.
WHO FEELS THEY ARE UNFAIR?
WHY?
JULIA?
>> I DON'T SEE THE PRESIDENT AS
A PERSON THAT IS RACIST.
HE HAS SHOWN THAT HE HAS HAD
MANY PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS, ETHNIC AND
EVERYTHING.
I DON'T THINK RACE IS THE ISSUE.
I DON'T LIKE YOU.
I DON'T CARE BECAUSE -- [LAUGHS]
BECAUSE OF WHO YOU ARE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER YOUR
BACKGROUND WHETHER YOU ARE
ENGLISH, GERMAN, WHITE OR ASIAN,
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT'S CONSTANTLY USED TO MAKE
THIS MAN LOOK BAD.
USE SOMETHING DIFFERENT, TRY
SOMETHING NEW.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE HERE BELIEVE
THE CHARGE OF RACISM IS USED TO
CASUALLY IN THE UNITED STATES?
RAISE YOUR HAND?
>> CLYDE?
>> I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
IS THE LAST GASP OF THE
DESPERATE GROUP THAT NEEDS VOTES
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE AND YOU NOTICED IT VERY
QUIET, AND NOTHING WAS SAID
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT HE HAS
SAID SUCH AS JEWS BEING TERMITES
AND GOING BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
TIME THAT HE FIRST GOT STARTED.
SO I WOULD SAY THEY ARE JUST
USING THAT, AND I'M NOT SAYING
THAT BUT YES, WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT'S KIND OF A
NEWBIE ABOUT BEING A PRESIDENT
AND, HE'S USING HIMSELF BEING A
HUMAN BEING.
IF YOU CRACK A HISTORY BOOK, YOU
WOULD SEE WHO VERY SURELY AS THE
PERSON WHO -- >> IF YOU CRACK A
HISTORY BOOK YOU WILL SEE THERE
IS A HISTORY BASED ON RACE.
>> YOU WILL FIND A DEMOCRAT FROM
DAY ONE.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
POLITICAL PARTY, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT -- WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT POLITICS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT -- I LET
EVERYBODY TALK, LET ME MAKE MY
POINT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT, BASED ON
RATES, AFRICAN-AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN ENSLAVED.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AFTER 1865
WERE SUBJECT GRADED TO JIM CROW
LYNCHING, AND DISENFRANCHISING
BASED ON RACE.
SO THE ONLY PEOPLE PLAYING RACE
IDENTITY POLITICS HAVE NO MERIT,
THERE IS A HUGE MERIT.
>> IT'S ALSO THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY.
SHE ASKED A SPECIFIC QUESTION.
>> Laura: ONE AT A TIME.
>> SHE ASKED A SPECIFIC QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER TRUMP IS RACIST.
HE'S NOT.
IT'S AN EXCUSE, THERE IS NO
PROOF AND THERE IS NO
BACKGROUND.
MY GOOD FRIEND MARION MENDOZA
KNOWS HIM -- THIS IS NOT
PERSONAL.
YOU MAKE A CONVOLUTED ARGUMENT
WHEN YOU START BRINGING IN -- >>
I'M NOT MAKING A CONVOLUTED
ARGUMENT.
>> ONE AT A TIME.
>> Laura: ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
IN THE UNITED STATES, WE WILL
GET INTO THIS, ECONOMICALLY AND
WHETHER THAT HAS AN EFFECT AND